so what you're about to see is a really
interesting interaction a lovely lady
that I kind of a spoke on the stage
after my talk and then came up and got a
book and then she came back and kudos to
her to ask a question about her business
and a you know as you guys know normally
I'm giving one or two quick answers
because I don't have time and
unfortunately in settings like this but
something caught my attention and I dig
into the details and get into some of
the kind of questions I would ask if I
were with you and kind of the questions
that I would hope that you're asking
yourself as you're trying to figure out
why something's not working
I learned a lot today my story is I had
one shot one year ago American barbecue
nobody knows about barbecue here really
been really good really good
and then that stretched my revenue you
move too fast what you're not sure why
it happened no actually not is it
American what my message
let me help you let me help let me help
you a little bit let me help you the
first thing I would do - I love you
personally I love you for being honest
to say I don't know what went wrong is
very important very powerfully if you go
backwards the first thing I would do if
I like if I was buying 50% of your
company now we're partners I would say
okay
first meeting 9:00 a.m. 7:00 a.m. you
know first feeding
tell me everything tell me what you did
everything he did when you when you were
running one truck and then tell me what
you did you you when you had three my
belief is that when you had one all the
energy was going in one places which
means you were going further down the
line deeper and somewhere in there was
the most important thing that you had to
not be able to do when you became the
manager of three and that's it and
that's it I can tell you I'm telling you
what's very exciting for me to be
probably probably no no definitely not
that definitely not that I give it to
respect definitely definitely not
diversity definitely not if it worked at
one it would work at a hundred you stop
doing something at three that you used
to do at one that became the
vulnerability so did you use to be the
front of the truck
great now you're not you can't be in
three trucks so the next question
becomes are the two people that are in
the front of the truck not the kind of
people that people want to buy barbecue
from maybe maybe not I don't know next
next you could take a step back the I
believe you the quality of the food but
everything I would ask was the food
consistent did you have the same exact
ingredients do you have like pull that
probably yes because that's not that
hard but maybe not maybe you had a
little less stiff foot maybe you had a
spread I don't know what your allocation
punished me
understood so let's go back the nut one
truck did it stay in a certain area does
it still stay in that certain area is it
still doing the same revenue or down
understood and your overhead is greater
than what you're getting let me ask you
a question
[Music]
yes
I got an idea can you type in the
address where you where you park the
cars yeah good type it yeah I mean it
goes so detailed
that's how you win its entrenches yeah
that's okay I'm going to show you
something
every day what time do the trucks start
up operating I'm going to show you
something that I want you to do I want
you to click this every day every day
you have Instagram right okay so this is
that talent that you're in right I want
you to click a photo of the person right
and so you'll you'll get the person
right and I want you to send a message
do you know how to do that
you sure I want to make sure you get
this when you go on somebody's profile
the buttons up here and then send
message saw your profile come by my
truck today from 1 to from 11 from 11 to
2 o'clock and I'll give you a free
barbecue I want you to do that 10 times
for 20 times every single day it's my
belief that now pay attention to what I
showed you
I'm gonna go a little slower when you go
to a town and when you get to your phone
maybe you can even say the street so it
can be even closer when you go there
what it shows you on Instagram is that 9
posts the 9 posts that are the most
popular and then in order the people
that did it the most recent see she did
this 30 minutes ago so either it's
people that are right there right now or
it's people with bigger influence who
are there cuz you know I could tag
myself here but then I'm gone right but
if you look she has 3,000 followers
maybe she lives there if you message her
and say I like your Instagram profile I
like Instagram my food truck is here
come by and I'll give you free lunch
today I believe one in every 10 will
come every day and I believe that 10%
catching great but you're giving it for
free hear me out one in every 10 will
come
and then one in every 10 of those
because you're not gonna ask it's gonna
post and say delicious but I believe
that that is worth 30 minutes of your
time every day here's why
my numbers could be totally wrong four
out of every ten could come and three
out of every ten of those could post but
here's what's more important one post
you get the right girlfriend of a soccer
player you get the right influencer one
post can change your business overnight
that's one little tactic that I want you
to do it will work it might reject now
go back so I know I'm going macro on the
micro you know me me Howard if you sold
one of your trucks and went to two I
would look at the mass of what that
would look like
I would intuitively I I'm not ready to
make a call and have to look at your
business more carefully intuitively to
feels right and three does that for you
but they don't
how close are you do the revenue thirty
percent to thirty of the hundred percent
what are you doing to market anything
what about Instagram Instagram you have
to understand why Facebook when you post
something one percent of the audience
season organically Instagram is 40
percent organic video nope you you're
sitting in the truck and you take a
picture or take a picture of the meal or
take a picture of the line or take a
picture of one person or take a picture
of the flowers that are across the
street from your truck build a micro
local presence because you have a micro
local business interview people maybe
and this might not come natural to you
but maybe first slow
Instagram
you know let me know good to see you
[Music]